Trascrizione: Irene Fioresino
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Questo è un report scientifico,
contiene informazioni utili, e dati,
che possono aiutarci ad affrontare
il cambiamento climatico.
Ma purtroppo è un media
disegnato da esperti,
e che molti di noi
non riescono a comprendere.
L'ho scaricato da Internet,
quindi è facile usufruirne.
Io, fondamentalmente,
traduco questo media in questo:
in immagini sexy, chiare e potenti
che possono essere diffuse
sui canali popolari, pop,
a disposizione di tutti,
come i social network,
le mostre e così via.
Questa, per esempio,
è un'immagine evocativa
di una serra in Islanda
che vive in totale simbiosi
con il vulcano che sta alle spalle.
Quindi prende l'energia geotermica,
coltiva con le ceneri vulcaniche,
e rappresenta, per me,
quel tipo di obiettivo
che l'uomo sta cercando,
quel rapporto di simbiosi
tra uomo, natura e tecnologia.
Io ho iniziato questo percorso
20 anni fa, nella foresta amazzonica,
durante un viaggio da informatico
con la prima macchina fotografica in mano.
Lì ho costruito
una consapevolezza maggiore
e un'importanza forte della natura per me,
cioè quello che mi faceva
stare veramente bene.
E anche della fotografia
applicata alle soluzioni.
E vi porto ora in un tour,
in questo, chiamiamolo, report visivo
di alcune delle soluzioni che ho trovato
e delle storie avvincenti.
Qui siamo di fronte a un uomo
che insieme ad altri 1000 uomini
decommissionano da oltre 30 anni
una centrale nucleare
nel nordest della Germania,
che dava energia a tutta Berlino.
Pulisce metallo e superfici contaminate,
per rimetterle poi sul mercato.
La rivoluzione energetica tedesca
è un programma governativo
che si pone come obiettivo
di spegnere 22 centrali
nucleari entro il 2022.
Un reattore nucleare dura trent'anni.
Sempre dentro questa storia,
io cercavo un simbolo
di questa rivoluzione tedesca,
e ho trovato questa torre
di raffreddamento
che è stata trasformata in una giostra,
proprio a rappresentare
la speranza di questo paese
e a diventare un'icona.
Un'icona che ritroviamo anche
in questo inceneritore a Copenaghen,
ultima icona, mi viene da dire,
industriale nata sul pianeta,
che ho fotografato il giorno
della sua inaugurazione.
È un inceneritore a emissioni zero,
capace poi di trasformarsi
e lavorare senza spazzatura,
ma con biomassa,
che funziona anche come pista da sci,
come potete vedere,
e come centro di educazione
per i cambiamenti climatici,
quindi è un punto di connessione
tra i muscoli industriali
e la cultura delle persone.
Spesso queste cose succedono in Europa,
siamo molto più avanzati
rispetto ad altre parti del mondo.
Qui siamo di fronte a una foresta
di turbine eoliche nel Mar Baltico,
che cerca di creare
l'energia rinnovabile del futuro
per un'alleanza di paesi del Nord Europa.
Questo è un traghetto trasformato in casa
per questi tecnici, che io
amo chiamare Energy Cowboys,
che vivono in alto mare, nel freddo,
e che escono tutte le mattine
a installare queste turbine eoliche
per creare questa energia.
E quando parliamo di dati importanti,
non possiamo dimenticarci le proteine.
Le proteine sono un grosso problema.
La creazione di proteine
è un grosso problema,
per l'impatto ambientale.
Per esempio, qui siamo
nel centro di Londra,
esattamente nel centro,
dove questa startup alleva insetti
usando cibo locale e scarti di caffè,
che vengono poi dati
agli animali, da mangiare,
ed è un esempio di economia circolare
che può creare veramente un vantaggio
nell'impatto ambientale
della creazione delle proteine.
Ma anche noi, come diceva
giustamente Luca,
abbiamo bisogno di coltivare di più,
molto di più, con un minor impatto.
Questa è la casa del contadino
del futuro, in Olanda.
È circondata da serre automatizzate,
e ci può far immaginare
come il futuro dell'agricoltura
potrebbe essere fra qualche anno.
Sempre in un processo
di economia circolare,
dobbiamo assolutamente recuperare
quelle abitudini del passato,
che abbiamo perso,
dove non si buttava via nulla.
Cioè, è proprio l'altro ieri.
Il distretto tessile riciclato di Prato
rigenera lana dalla spazzatura tessile.
È la prima volta che mi trovo
di fronte a una storia
dove il futuro assomiglia al passato.
Dobbiamo anche ricordarci di un alleato
molto importante, che è la natura.
I processi naturali
devono essere riportati
al centro dell'equazione climatica.
Questo bioreattore di alghe, per esempio,
pulisce le acque sporche
di una piccola cittadina
del Montana, negli Stati Uniti,
e restituisce a sua volta
una polvere verde naturale
che può essere trasformata in bioplastica.
La natura salva la natura.
Come le posidonie oceaniche,
quella macchia nera di cui abbiamo paura
o confondiamo con alghe
quando si spiaggia, no?
In realtà contengono il segreto
delle acque cristalline del Mediterraneo,
come la Sardegna, dove ho scattato
questa foto di recente.
Pensate che sono capaci
di assorbire 15 volte in più
di una pianta dell'Amazzonia
della stessa dimensione,
cioè praticamente
sono la nostra Amazzonia,
che però soffre a causa
delle nostre ancore, un paradosso.
Insomma, in questo tour che vi ho fatto,
ci si accorge che ci sono
forti potenzialità,
che si sono tantissime cose
presenti nell'adesso,
cioè sono cose che esistono
e che possono essere
scalabili e ripetibili.
Quindi dobbiamo osservare il presente,
per scatenare un futuro più sostenibile.
e comprendere e far comprendere
di più la scienza,
perché dobbiamo ascoltarla,
ma abbiamo bisogno di comprenderla meglio.
Quindi io cerco di tradurla
in un modo più comprensibile
per questo motivo,
perché dobbiamo riuscire a coinvolgere
più persone possibile nel cambiamento,
per poter agire come un'unica forza.
E utilizzando i canali popolari,
per esempio mostre, Instagram,
tutto ciò che ci può essere utile
per diffondere questo messaggio,
perché di base noi abbiamo
assolutamente bisogno
di riagganciare quell'anello spezzato
tra speranza e futuro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)